you cannot have a successful marriage
without compromise you know you cannot
be a successful person unless the v your
views change as you get older and wiser
right it's only in politics where you
have to believe the same thing for 30
years otherwise you're a bad person it's
only in politics where talking to the
side and trying to find common ground is
considered is considered the devil's
work um
and uh i i just i just i call bullen and
i've worked with i've worked with both
sides because i preach bipartisanship i
won't i won't work with a candidate but
i'll work with parties and i've worked
with both parties and i can tell you
some funny stories
um and i've had private conversations
and i'll tell you one of them
so i sat down with the congressman just
me and the congressman no no staffers
around us
and and and i had the uncomfortable
conversation which i wouldn't have
publicly with them because uh it's just
inappropriate and i said you know what
your problem is
is you're not willing to sacrifice for
this country
i said i know
men and women who wear a uniform who
would lay down their lives for this
country
and you won't even give up your job for
this country oh and by the way if you
lost your election you're going to
become a lobbyist or some consultant and
you'll make more money than you've ever
dreamed of so my question is what
exactly are you losing whether you keep
your job or lose your job the answer is
nothing power
and uh right and but the point is that
they're in a win-win situation i'm
either powerful or i got cash like
that's your choice
um
and
you looked at me and said you're right
none of us are none of us are willing to
and this is not what our founding
fathers intended our founding fathers
intended that you would leave your law
practice you would leave your farm you'd
come and serve your nation for a few
cycles
and then you go back to your career we
have professional politicians now people
who've been in office for 30 years
they actually don't know how to do
anything else take anybody who's been
doing something for 30 years and say
you're going to stop doing it and fear
is the motivation as well we our
founding fathers never wanted a class a
professional politician that was never
in the in
in the design of this nation
um
so i i think there's there's um my my
this is a horrible thought but it's a
thought that i've struggled with
for for years now and i and i cannot
reconcile it which is um
we we lost something when the berlin
wall came down
which is we lost an external existential
threat
we always fought we always disagreed but
at the end of the day we could come
together and say uh
that's
not that that threatens all of us and so
we could come together
in defense of of our of our beliefs and
our nation
and when the berlin wall came down and
we lost uh a perception because it still
exists we just lost the perception of
the external existential threat what
happens it's a weird quirk of humanity
which is vision and positive stuff and
all this stuff is all ethereal but
negative stuff is usually tangible
and so it's a weird quirk of humanity
that it's that it's that i can more
easily define what i stand for when i
can see what i stand against
but if that thing that i stand against
doesn't exist then it's very hard for me
to articulate what i stand for
and so i look for something that i'm
against to help me understand what i
stand for
and so if it doesn't exist outside our
borders i'm going to look
inside our borders and we start to see a
massive increase of
infighting inside our nation
because we don't have any sense that
there's something threatening us
as a tribe